Did feminists ever stop to consider that some of us did not wanna leave the kitchen?
like I would make all the sandwiches and grab all the beers
if it meant I could stay home
I’d be content with that
I don't want a man in my kitchen spraying the Pam all over the counters
or seasonings covering it
guys can't multitask and clean as they go
I’d just be more stressed about the state that they leave my kitchen in
stay out of my kitchen
and I will stay out of the workplace
I'd be okay with that
I don't want Equality
obviously I don't want someone to like
physically hurt me
but I don't wanna sit there and split all the bills
I wanna be someone's dainty princess,
feminine princess
I want them to come home after hard day
they see me they kiss me
and all their stress just melts away
I have dinner ready on the table when he comes home and he says
this smells delicious
it's the best meal I've ever had,
enjoys every last bite,
tells me how much he loves me
that's what I want
I don't want Equality
you can have the workplace
leave it to the men
I'll stay in the kitchen